am I getting so tired already it's fun
it's so cool this is about a 40 pounds
worth of stuff there's like so many
different textures in here I don't think
this is doing anything but it's fun
oh wow Wow
[Music]
welcome back to tasties making it big
this is the show where I make giant food
for my friends and special guests today
I've invited in Kalin Allen you guys
have might have seen his viral reactions
to release really awesome food videos
and I'm really excited because I've
always wanted to see he'd react if I
cook for him so let's go meet him okay
well hello hello what's going on how are
ya good
big fan oh well thank you very much I
know a lot of people out there probably
know what you're famous for but in case
some people don't what do you do so
essentially my main job is I react to
food videos how did you get into this
like where did it all start I was on my
way to work and I was like Lena my BAE
and I was going through it was actually
a tasty video came up and it was at this
cornbread and I was like oh actually
make a video to this now put up my phone
first record and unreal O's history I've
definitely learned a lot from watching
you react to other people's videos I've
definitely been more cautious about the
way I approach the stuff that I make and
I would love to cook for you today and
make you something really really giant
what sorts of foods are you into I am
into a lot of food that I love I love
Italian as well okay yeah are there any
dishes that you think maybe you would
like to request for me to make I mean
the doors wide open
spaghetti Oh like spaghetti meatballs or
just spaghetti spaghetti meatballs okay
so that means a meeting like giant
spaghetti and giant meatballs I actually
liked it a lot of people get mad about
it I like sugar in my spaghetti Oh
interesting I like my spaghetti to be
sweet I want to get working on the food
but I might call you back in you know
cuz I would love to see you react
real-time to some of the stuff near the
end because that's where all the food's
coming together so I'll get to work and
then I'll call you back for some
reactions later okay
okay we're gonna make some Giants we're
gonna get meatballs in giant spaghetti
meatballs the first thing as well the
spaghetti so we're gonna start with
fresh pasta we're gonna bill in with 8
cups of flour and some salt and then
we're gonna mix this together with a
fork to evenly incorporate the salt with
the flour this is 8 cups of flour it's
actually a quarter of the total batch
because we if you do it all at once
it'll be kind of crazy so the amount of
dough we're making here seems like a lot
and that's only 1/4 of the whole thing
so that's pretty cool
so once the flour and the salt are mixed
you want to go in make kind of like a
little well like you do after you get
the well we're going in with the eggs
this is a dozen eggs that's 12 and we
have a little bit of water to also help
this come together you don't really want
to go in to mix everything you kind of
want to like whisk all this all these
eggs and water and get it into a nice
mixture first so that it's more evenly
incorporated that's why we made the well
the whole entire pasta batch for Kalin's
giant spaghetti meatballs is going to be
32 cups of flour and 48 eggs also known
as a lot of stuff so can yell at
whirlpool am I getting so tired already
it doesn't all have to come together in
the bowl you just need to get it to
consistency where you can dump it out
and also I just want to stop doing this
so we're gonna dump this out and
continue to knead that goal is to kind
of shimmy it into a workable dough yeah
this is its own unique workout if you
make pasta from scratch every day we're
gonna be really jacked in like one arm
and then the great thing is that this is
also your sponge so you can just do this
it's been about 10 minutes and I think
the reason why you have to kind of go
for so long is because it's a pretty
large portion of dough it really worked
the gluten you got to get all the liquid
from the egg all the fat from the egg to
really combine with the flour but it's
looking pretty good now
this one sounds looking cool it's been
about an hour I've made a total of four
giant pasta dough balls and they've all
been resting at room temperature for at
least thirty minutes this is the one I
most recently made her name's Gertrude
and we're gonna cut gertrude into 16
pieces to roll through this pasta
machine Emma straight down the middle oh
yeah
eight look at that
16 totally not even pasta triangles and
we're gonna get this into a sort of like
a rectangular shape a little bit of
flour want to turn on our pasta machine
right now is that the thickest setting
this is a one setting and because it's
on a stand mixer the stand mixer is
going to do a lot of the work for me
which is nice enough to do myself
all right and stand mixer is also on the
lowest power setting so it isn't just
like shoot out pasta everywhere are we
gonna do that a couple of times so you
can get it to be a little thinner it's
so nice having someone else do the
rolling out for me I just kind of hold
it and caress it and let it go so that
looks pretty good it's gotten a lot
longer than we started at this point
we're gonna go to the second setting cuz
if you go from one to like three too
fast it'll like bottleneck in here and
there's gonna be a big traffic jam and
nobody's gonna be coming out smooth
everybody to be pissed
they're like Swan Lake should be playing
right now
all right 15 worker Trude pieces to go
so now that they're rolled into these
long sheets I do want to cut them into
really wide and big noodles I got a
really cool toy this is a pasta bike
kind of like an accordion it almost be
like an old-school torture device oh
[Music]
it's so cool we have essentially is
really really nice pasta noodles like
that this is one noodle it's like it's
like 2 feet long that's awesome you in
pressure even pressure all the way
through nice I think that's why they
call it a pasta pipe it literally feels
like you're riding a bike through a
field of pasta that's kind of a dream
this is Gertrude now reborn into a
almost like flower like Picasso painting
but this is only one of the four dough
babies that I have to get there so I'm
gonna go put this in the back and I'm
gonna ride my bike for another hour or
so so uh I have to make giant meatball
I'm not really sure how if you just make
a ball that big and you bake it it'll
like kind of flatten in the oven and I
really want a nice like spherical kind
of shape so I'm gonna try to search up
Giants you her ball yeah they're all
like sphere moles large ball bowls for
cocktails like 3 inch 4 inch I'm not
that's not good okay okay so apparently
there's like these cake pans that are
like hemispheres that apparently they
use for like those dome shaped cakes
they say sports cake pans I'm assuming
it's like those cakes where it's like a
soccer ball a basketball a big one
that's how they make those and I think
if I can actually get two of them I
could potentially put meat and like make
like a big sandwich and then
bacon oh there's like a there's like a
specialty Bake Shoppe a couple couple
miles and I put my eggs in one basket
and hope that they have it so I'm gonna
go shopping and I'm gonna go get those
bolts well I found these at the store
these are nice big hemisphere molds I
told the guy that I was gonna be making
meatballs and he was like yeah we use
those for cakes and I was like making a
cake put some sheets in crimp it around
the edge and we use this guy to press it
down make a nice little shape all right
let's try to make things nice and even
here look at that nice me both Bissell
we have 27 pounds of ground beef and
this is gonna make for meatballs we have
48 eggs
have a lot of Parmesan cheese we have 12
cups of bread crumbs
fun fact every four slices of bread is 1
cup of bread crumbs so we just throw in
forty eight slices of bread and with the
amount of eggs we just put in here plus
the Mel we used in the pasta this is
close to 100 eggs 2 onions Italian
seasoning salt garlic powder and pepper
this is about I'm gonna say 40 pounds
worth of stuff what's in wild it's like
so many different textures in here don't
really want to talk about it an average
meatball is around one ounce so 27
pounds of ground beef is equivalent to
four hundred and thirty two ounces of
beef so these four giant meatballs will
be the size of 432 meatballs like
punching it
I don't think this is doing anything but
it's fun the goal here is to make sure
that we don't have any lumps or pockets
or clumps of any of those individual
ingredients I want to get all this into
one homogeneous mass so we're gonna be
here for a long time we're ready to put
the mixture inside of those foil balls
but we do need to spray those molds
first because you don't want them to
stick this mixer makes four meatballs
and this is one meatball so I'm gonna
try to divide this up into like a
quarter and try to compress it I kind of
want this to also come above the lip of
the meatball because meats gonna shrink
in the oven and if you cook it and it's
below it'll just like dirt and then
it'll become smaller and it'll be fine
it'll work Sarge the meats into the
quarters okay let's just do this we're
gonna squeeze hard it's like a meat
sandwich kind of looks like Piranha
Plants that was one I want to make three
more use up the rest of this bad boy
over here and we're gonna make them all
off for a very very long time until
they're cooked and pray that they retain
their sphere shape
it's been about uh three hours the
meatballs are almost ready they look
crazy there's like four giant Death Star
things in there we're just trying to
time it so that by the time the
meatballs come out the noodles are
coming out so we're gonna boil the
noodles we got but the first thing that
we have to do is we have to obviously
salt the pasta water so go here it's
really hot we're gonna go in with these
noodles go in here okay so because this
is fresh pasta it cooks very quickly but
these are thicker noodles so we're gonna
cook them for about four to five minutes
hopefully we'll have some delicious
bouncy al dente thick pasta noodles okay
so these are pretty much ready big
spatula big spider we got whoa that's
pretty awesome
Faye's they're going here one of there
was some oil on it so they don't stick
and then just to taste
hmm we're really good it's a great first
batch we're gonna go with a second one
here I think is to keep the water going
in a vortex as the noodles go in so that
it don't stick alright second batch is
ready it's coming out nice and bouncy
and springy you know with some oil just
like the Gordon Ramsay olive oil in
perfect please don't be mad Gordon mmm
I'm gonna go cook like 20 more though
and then a little bigger
all right cool welcome to the set Kayla
thank you doing I'm exciting you're
hungry I'm very hungry what do you think
of all this stuff we got so okay so I
noticed that those aren't spaghetti
noodles aren't those what are those
called pin it started peed on it
let's start with the P Papa de Leon
something like that hey I think that's
what it say on the menus Papa deli Papa
deadly yeah I mean we cut them and you
know we made them by hand and then we
just like cut them really long with the
power I'm gonna start by putting down
the pasta noodles now where you gonna go
pants bro I don't know our department
got them from the hardware store they
may or may not be pants now when you
bought them noodles do you see these in
the water I'm I season the water ok
composers be throwing it up in the water
and bling and noodles that knock you how
many eggs do you think it took to make
this uh this batch of pasta you know
what I've never made fresh pasta before
so I'm a guest I'm gonna say 15 4848 a
lot of chickens huh oh yeah it was busy
how long you been cooking I've been
cooking since I was in high school did
you go to culinary school
no not only did I learn to cook you okay
yeah my mom taught me over speakerphone
while she was in China yeah she
literally yell at me and tell me what to
buy so this is our nest of pasta noodles
you can tell it's making a nice landing
zone for the meatballs beautiful that is
impressive
they look like planning you know you can
take those together and put that in
somebody solar system for a science fair
project oh wow oh wow
Wow
Oh Quan well great color to them too
yeah there's a good sear on it right
uh-huh uh-huh Wow is juicy too
Wow this is insane we got the sauce here
beautiful per your request there's a
little bit of sugar in here oh thank you
so you want to taste it that's
perfection where you get a ladle they'd
be a same restaurant supply store I
don't know but it's made like the super
Style section
it's the area 51 section yeah here you
go oh wow I was like a volcano smoke
it's hot and really baby how many
tomatoes I don't know I think the whole
farm how do you feel about this amount
of sauce I think it looks great
all right cool cuz we're not done yet I
gotta garnish it Oh
okay what we garnish it we got some
cheese a man now listen when I go to
Olive Garden I'm always a present you
know when they'd be like well tell me
when could we be sitting there for five
minutes
giggle go ahead garnish that thing with
that cheese you all want yeah anyone
else order some good cheese oh yeah
people in there on you all right I got
you
how do you feel about parsley I you know
I think less is more the taste of the
person food
oh yeah lesson definitely more with this
parsley Jesus almost took me out a
little bit never know okay that's know
this is it yeah some we can eat now
however you think this is I would guess
is to be probably around fifty pounds
yeah that's there that's heavy okay
heavy that's real heavy okay you ready
to eat I'm ready
all right what would you like to start
with first but I feel like we need to
plate it again yeah so we need to grab
some noodles first down okay
okay this is crazy comin here this
little crevice right here give me some
sauce look at that oh I was like
tableside prime rib no good here you go
sir thank you some tableside meatballs
Alec thank you so much just cut myself a
slice of meatball nobody ever says that
yeah cuz they don't have to yeah
all right Cheers you outdid yourself at
this one mmm this best damn me behind
they ever had its moist
you would think you know with that big
not dry it's not dry then it's not dry
at all
I mean it's seasoned very well thank you
if there's a lot of flavor in there how
many'd you to open up a restaurant I'm a
giant food that's it oh yeah you know
it's LA so all the instagramers to go
crazy because then going to take
pictures or put a big big pink wall yeah
sorry that's all you need
go big or go home okay mm-hmm my posture
still got a little bit of bounce to it
mm-hmm
it's not overcook ain't that crazy
now people with like an ounce of
bouncing and overcook you'd have made
all this possible you need this perfect
well thank you they make Tupperware just
be it I only get my Tupperware that we
can go to Bed Bath & Beyond to find a
bathtub okay don't work thank you so
much for coming today thank you for
coming
I'm glad you like you feel free to keep
on eating okay but see you guys next
time bye y'all I'm staying
[Music]